mauvaise opération pour l'équipe de
football de montigny le bretonneux dans
le championnat excellence les verts se
sont inclinés à domicile sur une pelouse
détrempée contre l'équipe 2 de
versailles après une première période
ponctuée par plusieurs occasions
franches les saint-quentinois ont levé
le pied après la pause et ont finalement
craqué dans les dernières minutes de la
partie défaite 1 0 on a mis en place des
choses qu'on a réussi à mettre en place
sur le terrain maintenant
c'est sur un petit détail à un coup
prend un coup de pied arrêté
certainement un problème de marquage
c'est dommage parce qu'on avait comme
j'ai eu des bonnes a bien travaillé à la
fin du match les saint quentinois sont
sortis très remontée au près de larbitre
ce dernier a décidé de ne pas accorder
deux penaltys using montrent un 1 but a
également été refusée en seconde période
après une poussette sur le gardien nous
rendons pas grand chose à dire c'est
comme ça
au classement montigny le bretonneux
descend la 9e place du championnat
seulement un point de l'avant dernier
lui en cours 50 angles nous on vient de
monter donc on vient avec beaucoup
d'humilité on est au milieu de tableau
que la priorité avait entendu cette
semaine à tenir maintenant la poule est
très homogène il ya tous les matches ont
accroché et on sait qu'en faisant une
petite série de victoires ça peut aller
très vite dans un sens comme dans
l'autre si c'est une série de hbo fait
malheureusement donc nous on va rester
ambitieux on va essayer d'aller jouer
les premières places et c'est un coup
d'arrêt aujourd'hui mais on va rebondir
rapidement on reste concentrés
solidaires et les efforts qu'on fait à
l'entraînement ça va finir par payer et
être un petit peu plus réalistes en
attaque montigny-le-bretonneux avant
dernière attaque du championnat avec 8
buts se déplacera sur le terrain de
maurepas la deuxième plus mauvaise
défense de la division ce dimanche 27
novembre à 15 heures au stade du bout
des clos